so it appears that the emoluments cases
against former president trump have now
all been dismissed as
moot and while a lot of people are upset
it's not as crazy as it seems because
federal courts have a requirement that
all cases have to be a case in
controversy so
the court can't decide things where it
doesn't have any power to do anything
and if you're thinking well he still
made all that money while he was
president you're right except that a lot
of these cases if not all of them
didn't actually seek damages they sought
perspective relief they
sought to stop him from doing stuff in
the future they didn't actually seek
retrospective relief
to get him to disgorge the benefits that
he had
and since trump is no longer president
there's really nothing the courts can do
now that being said it does leave open
the possibility that someone maybe the
biden doj might go after president trump
for damages and force him to disgorge
those benefits though there's always the
question of standing so stay tuned and
i'll see you
in court